aaron rodgers was recently trending on
twitter why because of a book on his
bookshelf yes you can't make this [ __ ]
up aaron rodgers was bragging about the
fact that he's ann reigns atlas shrugged
on his bookshelf and people on the
internet were trying to dunk on him left
and right saying this explains
everything of course he does well i
don't think that is necessarily as big
of a deal actually we should be
celebrating the fact that aaron rodgers
has atlas shrugged on his bookshelf why
because aaron rodgers is a critical
thinker he's an independent thinker he
doesn't simply take at face value
whatever he's told he is trying to
understand what decisions he needs to
make in his life what do i mean well
atlas drugs is a great example according
to wikipedia atlas shrugs 1957 novel by
anne rand it's her fourth and final
novel it's also her longest it's
considered to be her magnum opus in the
realm of fiction writing the theme of
atlas shrugged as described by rand is
that it's the role of man's mind in
existence the book explores a number of
philosophical themes from which rand
would subsequently develop objectivism
in doing so it expresses the advocacy of
reason individualism and capitalism and
depicts what rand saw to be the failures
of governmental coercion now i don't
know why people are dunking on this idea
of somebody who's trying to learn more
about reason individualism and
capitalism actually we should be
celebrating the fact that somebody is
critically thinking in our society we
have a national crisis of a lack of
critical thinking of independent thought
people simply just go with the herd now
this isn't the first time that aaron
rodgers has said something that most
people say wait why is he saying that we
go back aaron rodgers went on the pat
mcafee show and he had another great
point he said if science can't be
questioned it's not science anymore it's
propaganda and that's the truth and now
of course most people get mad because an
nfl quarterback is sitting there talking
about science and propaganda he's
reading things like atlas shrugged but
ultimately if you disagree with that
statement then maybe you should be
turning internally and understanding why
do i disagree with this doesn't that
make a lot of sense if science can't be
questioned it's not science anymore it's
propaganda and i tend to think that we
should be celebrating people with large
audiences people who have the attention
of millions and millions of americans
who are talking about things around
reason critical thinking independent
thought individualism and capitalism
kudos to aaron rodgers we need as many
people like him as possible and not only
does he have these thoughts but he's
willing to have the courage and the
conviction to go out whether it's on the
manning cast or monday night football or
it's on pat mcafee's show or others he
not only believes this stuff but he's
willing to say it and maybe our society
needs more people who are willing to
talk out against the mainstream
narrative people are willing to think
for themselves and people who are
willing to stand by their ideals kudos
to aaron rodgers i hope it continues